the Trump campaign is pushing back this
morning after President Trump was
criticized for drawing a parallel
between a surprisingly good jobs report
and George Floyd Friday the US economy
added two and a half million jobs last
month the president is declaring victory
saying he was right that the economy
would quickly bounce back once
coronavirus locked down started to lift
Ben Tracy is at the White House this
morning Ben good morning good morning
these jobs numbers are certainly
unexpected but very welcome news for the
White House this has been a rough week
for the president he's been widely
criticized by both Democrats and
Republicans for his response the racial
issues that are roiling the country even
I was surprised by this one this was
better than I thought I thought it would
be okay but I didn't know this president
Trump was clearly energized by the much
better than expected jobs numbers a
bright spot in a week where the White
House has been the focus of large
protests turning the area surrounding it
into a fortress of fences in armed
guards this is the largest monthly jobs
increase in American history I can't
think of that that's a long time right
economists had expected the country to
shed more than eight million jobs in May
and the unemployment rate to soar to
nearly 20 percent instead the economy
added 2.5 million jobs and the
unemployment rate fell to 13.3% 30
million Americans are still out of work
but during his economic victory lap in
the Rose Garden the president seemed to
imply that George Floyd would be pleased
with the jobs report
hopefully George is looking down right
now and saying this is a great thing
that's happening for our country there's
a great day for him it's a great day for
everybody the White House later claimed
the president was talking about the
fight for equal justice not the jobs
numbers former Vice President Joe Biden
did not see it that way
George Floyd's last words I can't
breathe I can't breathe
have echoed all across this nation and
quite frankly around the world for the
President to try to put any other words
in the mouths of George Floyd I frankly
think it's
twice on Friday the president refused to
take questions from reporters apparently
trying to avoid talking about the social
unrest across the country in the wake of
Floyd's death President Trump says his
plan to combat racism in America is a
strong economy
Asian America
President Trump is spending the weekend
here at the White House so he will
likely see and hear the tens of
thousands of protesters that are
expected to take to the streets of the
nation's capitol today Dana Ben thank
you